[Applaudissements]
quand je suis venu de ma province ah
j'étais pas mince j'étais pas gros enfin
bref il me restait toutes les chances
dans l'existence d'être un homme un
homme mais j'étais chanté avec les unes
et même avec les autres sans
rancune remédiz à tous ces aléas j'ai ma
manière à moi et le soir dans ma
garçonnière j'ai ma collection de
derrière en photo au-dessus de mon lit
quand je dis derrière je suis poli ou
mon tardon ma
garçonnière je me fais prier je fais des
manières je m'invente un bon scénario et
je fais la cour à mes photos ah mais
c'est que je suis obsédé je le confesse
la moindre fesse fant
idiot car depuis toujours ma seule
antise la convoitise mais oh mais ce
sont les femmes les femmes n'étant pas
un bon client du lourvre les seuls
chedœuvres que je couve et bien et bien
ce sont les pinuples que je m'en h
acheté dans les sex chopé le soir dans
ma garçonnière j'ai ma collection de
derrière en poster au-dessus de mon lit
quand j'ai derrière bien sûr je suis
poli
coument ma garçonni vers eux je me fais
prier je fais des
manières pu je glisse au fond de mon
dodo pour faire la Bou à mes photos oui
le soir dans
ma
cararçonnière je me fais Brill je fais
des manières je dis ni oui ni non je
suis beau mais je suis le donjuant de
mes
[Musique]
photos